[Music]
[Applause]
the armistice was signed by Germany in
the Allied powers at 5:00 a.m. on the
11th of November 1918
[Music]
this morning on a wet dawn in London a
piper marked that moment the Sun rose
the clouds cleared and thousands filed
onto white
[Music]
from the balcony of the Foreign and
Commonwealth Office the Queen that the
nation in remembrance as she does each
year
[Music]
[Music]
the Prince of Wales laid a wreath on the
Queen's behalf
the German president followed
they're wreaths side-by-side in a show
of the friendship that now exists
between the two countries the Prime
Minister represented the government she
was joined at the Cenotaph by former
Prime Minister's
[Music]
[Music]
thousands of veterans the young and not
so young March from force cars parade as
they do each remembrance some way every
one of them with a story
like that was a prisoner of war out in
the Far East he was a prisoner of war
for three and a half years and he like
all other prisoners had a really really
difficult time so we're here today to
represent me whom I thought it was goods
as well since it was the a hundred
anniversary since the war stopped it was
special this year to mark the centenary
of World War one there was a special and
people's perception 10,000 walked from
the mound to the Cenotaph all of them
descendants of soldiers who fought in
the Great War they are immensely proud
of their service and what they had died
for and I'm wearing my great
grandmother's brooch which she wore
every day for the rest of my life after
the two sons have been
100 years ago the people were on the
streets of London celebrating the end of
four long years of war thousands of
memorial flames were lit the Tower of
London for the final time they represent
everyone affected by war and back at the
Cenotaph Whitehall still closed to cars
people wandered around the monument that
was built in the years just after the
First World War
that's war the Great War changed the
nation forever and the nation hasn't
forgotten alistair bundle sky news at
the Cenotaph in london